[Music]
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the Sun exploded tomorrow that
star at the center of our solar system
that super hot ball of plasma that gives
us heat and energy and amazing
complexions well it's a ticking time
bomb the Sun is about 10 billion years
old but it's only expected to last about
another 5 billion years after that the
Sun will expand becoming a red giant
then it will shrink to become a white
dwarf a dying star cooling for the next
several billion years of course we'll
all be long gone before any of that
happens but still can you imagine what
it would be like to watch the Sun blow
up before your very eyes with a name
like supernova you'd think that a solar
explosion would be the most magnificent
fireworks show the world has ever seen
but in reality you likely wouldn't see
anything the Sun is 150 million
kilometres away from Earth and it takes
8 minutes for light from the Sun to
reach us and while that may seem super
far away in supernovae terms we don't
stand a chance for earth to be
completely safe from a supernova we'd
need to be at least 50 to 100 light
years away but the good news is that if
the Sun were to explode tomorrow the
resulting shock wave wouldn't be strong
enough to destroy the whole earth only
the side facing the Sun would boil
by instantly the lucky other half would
experience a rise in temperature that
would be 15 times hotter than the sun's
current surface temperature and
permanent darkness and without the sun's
mass keeping us in orbit earth would
likely start floating off into space
while its remaining inhabitants
desperately struggle to stay alive there
is a chance that our planet could lock
into orbit around another star that
might provide the same light and heat as
our Sun but by the time that happened
we'd all be long gone if we knew in
advance the day that the Sun would
explode then we could buy ourselves as
many as 1000 years of time provided we
had the resources to sustain ourselves
for that long and we could just a few
metres below the ground you walk on the
earth is maintaining a temperature of
about 17 degrees so if we had enough
time to prepare civilization could
continue to live by moving underground
into a huge network of fortified bunkers
within a week after the explosion the
surface temperature on earth would drop
to minus 18 degrees within a year
temperatures would plummet to about
minus 73 degrees at this point the
oceans would begin to freeze from the
top down within 1,000 years Earth's
atmosphere would freeze and collapse
leaving anything left on the surface
exposed to cosmic radiation and meteor
impacts hopefully by that point we'd
have found ourselves a new home the good
news is that if the Sun were to explode
and it will eventually happen it
wouldn't happen overnight when the Sun
does die it will be a long slow arduous
process taking place over billions of
years the Sun will get hotter and
brighter and it will start to expand
during this process it will lose its
outer layers to the cosmos leading to
the creation of other stars and planets
in the same way that the violet burst of
the Big Bang created Earth who knows
maybe new life could form can you
imagine a method earth a new humanoid
species it's hard to predict how our
galaxy might look billions of years from
now and it's especially hard to imagine
our solar system without the great
golden anchor that keeps us all together
but one day in the very very distant
future the Sun will expand and then it
will shrink maybe leaving room for a new
start to take its place and if by some
miracle humanity still exists at that
point where might we be living can you
imagine your descendants being born on a
space station well that's a story for
another what if